any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
i want to ask you these questions um so
there's a concept in judaism in my
religion which is of the ethical will
not a material will
and i give the example of alfred nobel
actually when he endowed this medallion
he endowed it to uh to go to the great
to the discovery
in physics or chemistry etc that had the
greatest
benefit to mankind he was never married
he was single he had no children
and uh and so he gave this wealth to the
actual prize itself the golden medallion
but he gave an ethical implication
to humanity which is that the winners of
it should make the world better i want
to ask you carlo
not in your material will which you know
i assume will have
you know book sales galore for the
remainder of all history but i want to
ask you in your ethical will
what wisdom do you most want to bequeath
to
those listeners in my audience who are
your ideological heirs
if not your biological heirs what wisdom
would you put in your ethical will
oh great question thank you um i i i i
there is something i i would like to
leave as an ethical
uh uh will which is the following
um i believe
that a that
our culture has made a mistake um
when it assumes that
if everything is natural then we are
naturally
egoistic i think this is just a
unproven and wrong assumptions uh
because there's no reason
for us to be egoistic the our aims are
determined by what we are by nature and
our
aim are naturally also altruistic
so um the foundation of morality
can easily be found just in what we are
and not outside from what we are very
good um as you know this is uh coming to
you from the university of california
san diego i'd love to have i know you're
in canada now and you're enjoying the
snow
but maybe you'd like to see the beach at
some point during your visit to norway
oh yeah
i guess i miss a warm beach so we'll
have to get you out here very soon but
uh i want to ask you about another
question about the future and then we'll
go to the past in just a minute but the
future question involves
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination we we think about
speculations and so forth and one of the
uh things that arthur c clarke did like
you he wrote
he wrote great prose but he also wrote
great science as well
and he has in 2001 a movie that you may
have seen
there's uh the appearance of this
monolith it's basically a time capsule
that these apes in africa see or these
these hominids see in africa
and then later it's discovered on the
moon and it's meant to be a message in a
bottle
that lasts for billions of years from
some unseen
possibly benevolent civilization and it
reminds me of richard feynman
and he said um the so-called cataclysm
question he said
if in some cataclysm all knowledge were
to be destroyed and only one sentence
passed on to the next generation of
creatures
what statement and i'm going to ask you
carlo would convey the most information
in the fewest words and he had this
famous um
answer which i'll tell you i think it's
made by atoms yes what would you put
on a billion-year time capsule carlo
that's hard i never talked about that
um
i don't know okay that's fair enough
maybe
or maybe maybe i should put that i mean
we're we're still very ignorant yeah
well it's interesting because i asked
that of my friend kamran vapha who i
have tremendous respect for
he is as we say in yiddish a mensch a
lovely human being i said what would you
put on your monolith
same question i just asked you and he
said the equations of string theory
and i found that very very interesting
and very provocative
i never judge i think it would not would
not
be so arrogant to say the equation of
loop quantum gravity i mean that might
be wrong yes
yeah i mean we could we could put the
basic equation that we know about
which is the eisen equation or the
equation of quantum mechanics or the
even the standard model
but you know all right so that's
like that's our i i think that the
the the knowledge about we have the we
have about the world is more complex
than just the fundamental equation of
physics we know more about the world
just for the moment of question physics
just because uh out of complexity there
is a more
staff that comes in i think what we
what i think it's the most important
piece of what we know is just awareness
that there is so much we don't know
or if you want to just say oh my my
answer is the opposite of the one of
vasa what what is out there yet to be
discovered
i believe is much more than what we have
discovered so far
very beautifully put okay final question
for you carlo involves going backwards
in time we just went forwards in time
but now we're gonna go backwards in time
uh arthur c clarke had three famous laws
the first of which we open
every podcast with which goes as follows
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
his second law i quoted at the very
beginning along with a cohelet with
ecclesiastes
for every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert
and his third law states that the only
way of discovering the limits of the
possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
that's the name of this podcast i want
to ask you
uh what would you tell a 20 year old
carlo revelli
uh this is going to seem impossible to
you carlo but
trust me go into the impossible what
advice would you give to your former
self
go your way and don't listen to the
advice that you hear around you
very good very courageous
did you struggle a lot as a young person
with people doubting your
abilities or your or your or your
potential
oh yeah especially the the main person
doubting my own abilities and potential
which was
myself we call that the imposter
syndrome
i i i didn't know about
my capacity but i think nobody knows
when one is young
but i did get get a lot of
advices of what to do if you want to
become a scientist
and i did the opposite i'm very happy i
did the opposition
i took what people were saying if you
want to become a scientist
just do what is fashionable to do and i
thought no if i want to be
a scientist i try to understand what we
know today about the world and i try to
understand where the good questions
and i go study those questions very
beautiful
yeah speaking of of that you know kind
of doubting yourself i asked barry
barish the same question
and he said yeah to have courage and
don't listen to the biggest critic which
is yourself and i said
don't tell me you nobel prize winner
have the imposter syndrome he said no i
do
in fact the nobel prize made it worse i
said what are you talking about
you won the nobel prize you know there's
18 people that are alive that
won the nobel prize and he said no when
i went to accept my medallion
uh i had to sign this log book and the
logbook
had every person who's ever won the
nobel prize stating that they received
their medal and he saw this guy
albert einstein he saw his signature and
he said it gave him chills
and he said he's not worthy and even
right now carlo i get chills
telling the story about him so even
nobel prize winners
can doubt their own abilities and doubt
the courage but thanks to the advice
that you give
and your wonderful writing i want to
commend you so much so promised uh
you'll come back when your next book is
out and maybe we'll do a third part
where we talk about galileo and what he
means as a man
as a physicist and as you know one of
the greatest
minds who ever lived on earth as far as
i'm concerned and i know you believe
that
carlo thank you so much for going into
the impossible with me i hope we can get
together
uh in person maybe here on the sunny
southern california beaches
and i wish you all the best and until
your next book egg land comes out
in a few months we'll have you back on
brian it was great talking to you thank
you very much for having me
my pleasure any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from the magic
[Music]
you